so tell me a little bit about your
background you have some interesting
things that people need to know sure
well first my name is Christy Reese I am
actually a third-generation Carnegie
Mellon alum we have seven alumni in the
family and we span all kinds of colleges
from h and SS to cfa to CIT and i'm
currently a staff member in the school
of music so i'm still here
congratulations that's fantastic so
besides all that pressure what made you
decide to come to Carnegie Mellon when
you were young stir sure um well you
know I actually have a twin sister who
was here for undergrad and grad and she
always teased me for not being a
carnegie-mellon student or alum but I
came here because I just knew that
everything here is quality like whatever
you choose to go in to be at fine arts
humanities or if you're interested in
computer science everything is great so
I knew that when I was looking for a
program in arts management that this was
the place I wanted to be so tell me
since you were loyal scott white what
made you choose to become a loyal Scott
oh it's almost as if the program chose
me as soon as I heard about it and saw
the plaid to the bone tagline I knew I I
had to be a part of it what do you do to
show your tartan pride well I market all
of our school of music events and I
certainly attend a whole bunch of them
but I also go to athletic events too and
I definitely contribute to the
University and I'm a proud contributor
my grandma still contributes my father
did this year as well so it's it's a way
to stay connected and to ensure that
future generations can benefit from
everything we have here another thing
people need to know I mean it isn't
always like how much one person
contributes but how many of us
contribute so talk a little bit about
that and and tell us why it's so
important for people to contribute to
the University to give back sure well I
mean it's not just about you know one
giant lump sum I mean it would be great
if we could all be like mr. Tepper you
know a name of school after ourselves
but actually it's more important to show
support in numbers you know even if
you're just donating your class here
like for me to 2007 so twenty dollars in
seven cents every little bit really does
count and you can actually see your
money being put to work here you see it
through the students and their hard work
performances competitions everything
that they're researching
doing and winning